if i were in your shoes i would rent for
one year and let's see how
your personal feelings about where you
want to live shake out and how that
market
uh starts to recover or not factually
not feelings and so you know what is it
you know how long is it going to be
before
uh you know before before the economics
start to work again
and i don't know i don't know the answer
to that uh if you had asked me in april
i would have said i would be right back
you know but i was i was so dumb i
thought they were going to
not leave entire segments of our culture
shut down
but that's how dumb i am well and not
only have they done that they even shut
it down
we don't the stimulus money you're not
doing that now now do you see now you
done got me
i know i know i did i just poked a bear
it's fun though
listen they don't shut down things we
got stimulus money they're talking about
they aren't doing it
so you can't work but you're supposed to
take care of yourself and your family
what are you supposed to do well
eventually what's going to happen
is that the politicians that are doing
this are going to be out of power
because
regardless of their party people are not
going to accept a lack of freedom
based on the math because we do know for
sure one you know several things we do
know now that we did not know early in
the pandemic
about the actual math the main thing we
know is is that apparently they don't
teach math in med school
that that one has been pretty solidly
figured out
and so uh and the ability to do critical
thinking around
what actually affects this and doesn't
affect this
it's um it i mean i had a guy just
really just give me a long speech the
other day
about how he wasn't going to get covered
because he wears a mask and i went dude
the purpose of wearing a mask is not so
you don't get it so you don't
give it that's right doesn't stop you
from
getting it so gee man i mean
where are we raising these people so um
but it's uh
uh you know i don't care if you wear a
mask but don't do it for the stupid
reason
right you know it's like you know if you
you're going to completely
be in a hazmat suit to not get it
i mean that's just just anyway so this
is the kind of stuff that's going on man
and it's affecting
people's lives like yours mark and so
that's why it's got us riled up
and uh um it's okay dave cove is gonna
go away after the election
you think so no politicians wanting to
control people are gonna go away after
the earth after the election
that's um hey people for real get out
and vote um
and not just here but on your state and
your city level
these people that are making decisions
sitting behind computers that don't
understand how business work
and how lives are impacted they need to
feel the
the the sting of these flippant
decisions come next election period
you know that does happen it really does
people thinking
you know they're not very hopeful about
it i remember several years ago
a decade plus ago um
you know we had an idiot republican
governor in tennessee
that tried to pass a state income tax we
don't have an income tax in tennessee
and the people of tennessee pitchforks
and torches
i mean the protests were shut down the
capital we filled up the entire capital
with tea bags
and this was before there was a tea
party by the way
i've always said i think the tea party
was somewhat born in tennessee because
of that
because people just said no
you're going to have to manage your
budget we're not paying any more taxes
you're going to cut spending and you
don't need to spend 412 thousand dollars
put
412 million dollars putting wildflowers
in the interstate medians
no no lie that was in the budget and so
crap like that
but he wants to start an income tax so
but there were a few
a handful of uh state legislators and
senators who came out and said
you know we agree with him we think and
and you know what on the next election
cycle
none of them made it oh really
completely cleaned them out every one of
them got voted out
not only to push the thing down right
now it's a constitutional amendment in
the state of tennessee
not allowing an income tax so eventually
you know you can vote enough people out
that are misbehaving
and misusing their power using bad
critical thinking skills
uh to where you can change things but oh
my gosh what a pain in the butt
it's called a democracy for a reason
people